[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos vamos a dedicar Este
programa especial a profundizar sobre el
globo chino hallado y derribado sobre
territorio estadounidense y a los otros
objetos que han sido identificados en
los últimos días objetos voladores que
han llamado la atención del mundo todo
empezó con un primer globo que sobrevoló
el territorio estadounidense durante la
primera semana de febrero Washington
dijo que era un globo espía chino y
Beijing aceptó que era suyo pero aseguró
que no era espía que se trataba de una
iniciativa civil para recolectar datos
principalmente meteorológicos pues desde
entonces son varios los varios los
objetos voladores que se han detectado
pero de los que hasta la grabación de
este programa no se tiene información
suficiente
era un orbe blanco gigante y cruzó el
espacio aéreo de Estados Unidos durante
casi una semana antes de ser derribado
sobre la costa de Carolina del Sur cerca
de mil Beach desde entonces Estados
Unidos ha derribado otros tres objetos
estos objetos no se conocen uno de ellos
se describe como un globo eso fue
derribado sobre Canadá el 11 de febrero
los otros dos objetos siguen siendo
pocos claros uno de ellos Fue descrito
como un objeto cilíndrico ese es el que
fue derribado el viernes 10 sobre Alaska
y hubo un derribo el domingo 12 que fue
descrito como una forma octogonal tras
el derribo del globo chino se desató una
tormenta de críticas y acusaciones
cruzadas entre Washington y Beijing la
Casa Blanca aseguró que este artefacto
era otro esfuerzo de China por reformar
el orden mundial que era una provocación
y el pentágono lugares estratégicos del
territorio estadounidense china aseguró
que se trataba de un incidente aislado
que el globo era civil y se defendió
indicando que Estados Unidos es el
principal espía en el mundo de hecho
dijo que was también había enviado un
globo espía a su territorio algo que
como era de esperarse negó la Casa
Blanca no obstante el presidente Joe
biden aseguró que las relaciones con
china Se mantenían en calma
Me pregunto qué tratan de hacer con esto
los chinos No solo recolectar
información de inteligencia cerca de
objetivos militares sino testear nuestra
respuesta nuestra respuesta militar
operacional nuestra respuesta política
en una crisis o conflicto usarían globos
para forzarnos a determinar qué hacer
los derribamos y gastamos municiones
costosas en ellos o nos centramos en la
lucha en el lindo Pacífico tenemos que
hacer ambas pero realmente Es una forma
grandiosa de hacernos gastar municiones
costosas
pero más allá de este incidente la falta
de información sobre los otros objetos
llamados en ocasiones ovnis porque son
objetos voladores no identificados
incluso ha hecho que se especule con que
pueden ser elementos o artefactos
extraterrestres algo que fue desestimado
por la Casa Blanca
sé que ha habido preguntas y
preocupaciones sobre esto pero no hay de
nuevo
de extraterrestres o actividad
extraterrestre con estos recientes
derribos quería asegurarme de que el
pueblo estadounidense supiera esto todos
ustedes lo sabían y era importante que
lo dijéramos desde aquí porque hemos
oído mucho al respecto después de estos
episodios incluso china instó a Estados
Unidos averiguar De dónde provienen los
objetos voladores que han sido
derribados en los últimos días y aunque
muchos generalizaron que todo se
trataban de globos Washington se ha
esforzado en explicar que son otro tipo
de objetos que se mantienen en el aire y
también la importancia de analizar los
restos para entender cómo funcionan y
con qué objetivo fueron lanzados además
resaltan que ha sido clave derribarlos
porque pueden significar un riesgo para
la Aviación civil
no voy a categorizarlos como globos los
llamamos objetos por una razón
ciertamente lo ocurrido en la costa de
Carolina del Sur por el globo espía
chino era claramente un globo Estos son
objetos no puedo categorizar cómo se
mantienen en el aire podría ser un tipo
gaseoso de globo dentro de estructura o
podría ser algún tipo de sistema de
propulsión pero claramente son capaces
de permanecer en el aire
insto a que no lo atribuyan a ningún
país específico no lo sabemos es por eso
que es tan importante tener en nuestras
manos los restos para que podamos
evaluar y analizar más a fondo lo que
son para algunos analistas es clave que
se mantenga el hermetismo mientras se
analizan los restos del globo como Pues
también de los otros objetos derribados
para que los expertos en inteligencia
puedan realizar modificaciones de
software y escribir algoritmos para
extraer los datos que pudieron ser
recolectados no obstante en el otro
costado están los analistas que indican
que el problema también radica en la
forma de comunicación de las autoridades
estadounidenses pues las dudas que
surgen y que no son resueltas dan lugar
a todo tipo de especulaciones entre el
público por eso es clave trabajar en
determinar los pasos a seguir con esta
situación como ejemplo por si en el
futuro se producen hechos similares
Estados Unidos y sus aliados deben
trabajar juntos para establecer Cómo se
realizan Las investigaciones sobre la
forma en que monitoreamos nuestros
cielos y potencialmente modificar las
leyes de respuesta para cuando sea que
encontremos objetos sospechosos en el
aire la administración biden no está
comunicándose correctamente ni se
apropia de la historia respecto a estos
objetos como resultado de eso hay mucha
paranoia e histeria Así que si se
enfocan en explicar lo que está pasando
podría brindar calma y comodidad a las
Mentes de las personas
esperamos pronto tener más información
sobre estos objetos por ahora así
llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a ampliar toda la
información en nuestra web France 24.com
[Música]